today really important subject today is
World Mental Health Day and Prince Harry
and singer ed sheeran are bringing
attention to the issue of emotional
health the two teamed up in a hilarious
Instagram video to share their very
important message take a look at this
this for me is a subject to the
conversation it's just not talked about
enough I think people all over the world
are really suffering well I've actually
been trying to write a song about this
actually his time we stood up and said
you know good we're not gonna take any
more weird ginger and okay this may be a
miscommunication but this this is about
World Mental Health Day oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah of course of course
yeah I knew that no no I definitely know
down in the earth so we're good yeah for
me
the clip ends of course with Prince
Harry urging people to reach out to
anyone who might be suffering in silence
there they're sort of making light of
the gingers unite thing but the real
message here is you know there are
millions of people including 47 million
people just in this country alone who
experience mental illnesses last year
and Prince Harry made news when he in
2017 he talked about reaching out to
some counselling to deal with the PTSD
and the mental illness of his mother's
death and there isn't a reason to suffer
in silence and it's something we're
gonna be dealing with here at CBS flood
we'll be tackling the issue of mental
health when we broadcast a special live
audience event called stop the stigma no
more shame and blame it's a conversation
about mental health and that's on
October 23rd